thank you
thank you and good evening everyone and
welcome to this evening's north meeting
of the northwest area planning committee
today 7th of july
2022 my name is councillor maddie
thompson i'm the chairman of this
committee
sorry getting messages again before we
commence the business of the meeting
there are a few housekeeping issues just
to run through we're streaming the
meeting live as well as recording and by
being present in the meeting you are
giving your consent to being recorded
when invited to speak please turn on
your microphone speak clearly
referencing a page or paragraph number
when referring to the agenda papers keep
your contributions as clear and concise
as possible and ensure your microphones
remain off when not speaking as this is
important for the live streaming to be
heard clearly
finally can i draw your attention to the
notices on the agenda papers regarding
the different levels within the chamber
and advise that the fire exit is the
door behind the top table
members may i draw your attention to the
members update with further information
on items five six and seven on the
agenda and ask you to note that item six
has been withdrawn by the applicant
uh so ms ferd can we have apologies for
absence please i believe this councillor
siddle
uh yes chairman just counsel thank you
lovely thank you
okay item three members it's recommended
the minutes of the meeting held on 15th
of june found on pages 7 to 10 are
approved as a true and accurate record
can i take them as read first of all
members
i so propose can i have a seconder
thank you councillor keys wins that
prize um
any matters of accuracy members or can
we agree those and if so by ascent is
that possible
great lovely thank you very much
so item four is declarations of interest
and i'll have to read this bit
to disclose the existence and nature of
any disclosable pecuniary interests
other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests relating to
items of business on the agenda having
regard to paragraphs six to eight
inclusive of the code of conduct for
members
members are reminded that they're also
required to disclose any such interests
as soon as they become aware should the
need arise at the meeting before anybody
tells me i know we've actually changed
codes of conduct but the principles
still apply
uh i've got councillor durham first
thank you chairman and nominate interest
that's a member of essex county council
who are statutory consultants thank you
thank you council fleming
thank you chair non-pecunery is a member
of essex county council who are
statutory consultees thank you thank you
so everyone yes thank you
so we move on to our first planning
application it's item five on the agenda
it's milton house which is kismet kebabs
limited we'll have the office's
presentation and then we have two people
to speak
to members of the public and i'll
introduce those after the presentation
thank you
thank you chairman good evening members
um yeah so a reference has been made to
um the members update um which has been
circulated um
if if members are minded to grant plan
permission for the development um there
are some um further
fairly minor amendments
officers would recommend to the the
conditions um
um if members were minded as a to
approve
so this is an application
um
its retrospective application
um for conversion of two buildings
various new buildings and extension to
existing buildings um along with
ancillary works um
and the the various uses of those
buildings are set out in the description
i won't
read it all out
so this is
a 1.7 hectare site located the west of
walden road and to the north of the
village of laxington it's within the
rural area but existing development um
there is existing development to the
north and south location of the
residential units close to the site are
outlining green on the drawing to the
right there which is dangly to the north
and milton house the south stroke east
so this is um
called existing and this is what was
there before the development
currently proposed was carried out
and with the main factory building um
indicated there and you've got modern
road on
to the right east
so this is the proposed site plan so the
the buildings the subject the
application have been labeled um a to f
um so we've got um
building a's and b which are
converted buildings building a
use proposed for storage and b
is proposed as a gym
or workshop for the site owners you've
got a new factory building c
and you've got building d which is a
small building used for demonstrations
and you've got building e1 which is the
main factory building um and the changes
of that building are extensions to the
front and rear and cladding
and being added to part of the building
and building e2 is for a new building
for maintenance for storage and building
f is a covered storage area
and you've got a sales office and
there's their sales and staff office
which is roughly
um centrally located there
hasn't got no hasn't got a letter but
that's that building there and then
you've also got um a partner players
entrance gates and fencing which are
around this area here and you've got
hard standing for parking and turning
then that the main area um is this area
to the to the west of the buildings
so the applications accompanied by a
very detailed noise assessment and
just to visualize i think i've included
this within the agenda
so this is a plan showing where all
those plant areas are on the site
so we'll go through the the buildings um
individually so this is the ancillary
storage building and they've got floor
plans there and um elevations
and then got building b which is now
shaped building
with the gym and the workshop referred
to earlier
and then got building c which is a new
factory building
and then you've got the small building i
refer to for demonstrations
and then you've got the existing the
main factory building this is what the
building
looked like before the extensions were
added
and then
that was the existing or previous
floor plans um
so this is the proposed elevations and
that the luminous green is the the
cladding that has been added and then
and the top um the top
image is the proposed front elevation
and
and then you've got two side elevations
and then the floor plan below shows the
extension front and rear um hatched in
green
and this is um
i thought it would probably come up at
some point during the meeting but this
is a location the plant on the map main
factory building
um which we can come back to later if
anyone's got any
specific questions about that
um again these elevations showing the
plant that um is
um in on site and to which a number of
mitigation measures are are proposed
the elevation at the bottom is the north
elevation which is the one adjacent to
dane lee the house
referred to earlier in the neighboring
property
so this is building e2 which is for
maintenance storage
the buildings are all fairly similar in
appearance they've got um all cladding
very similar materials
similar similar in height um
so then we've got the covered storage
area
at the top and the sales office to the
bottom
and this is the landfill panel i
appreciate you can't really see the
photos very well but the um it does
illustrate where the new landscaping has
been carried out so it's mainly around
the demonstration building along the
south boundary but it also includes an
element along the frontage
and it also this drawing also quite
clearly shows the new heart standing to
the west
and a drawing with the
showing the um turning area for hgvs
so um that area is is
in this area here but sort of a close-up
image showing a um the turning circle of
a
um articulated lorry be able to come in
turn around and and so leave the site in
forward gear
and the pros drainage plan so um at the
moment there um
[Music]
there well there is need to improve the
drainage both valve and surface water
from the site so as part of the
proposals there is proposal for a septic
tank to the west and also an attenuation
pond for surface water
and they're beyond buildings towards the
western boundary of the site
an aerial photograph and there's a rain
factory building there and then on that
drainage you can also see where the
neighboring property dain lee is and and
their their garden um
and how far back their their garden goes
in relation to the to the site these
buildings here um
are
i went there
on monday and
their
redundant farm buildings essentially
so we've got some photos here just to
illustrate what's there um there is
sales office building you've got the
building b which is the gym stroke
workshop
um
and then the main factory buildings you
can see the front extension here which
is slightly different color to the rest
of the building and then he's got the
side single story
so um rear extension um illustrated
there
picture of the containers which is part
of the application the storage building
um building a
demonstration building there
illustration of the fencing that is um
part of the application
um building c factory building
and then other various um photographs so
you've got building e
looking at the building from the south
west car parking outside the sales
office
different view of the containers
looking building the one bottom left and
that's looking at the main factory
building from
essentially malden road um outside
entrance there and you've also got the
picture
including milton house
and more photos um building c factory
building maintenance story building and
again the sales office which shows where
the htv turning area would be
yes
thank you
um yeah so the development includes a
suite of mitigation measures in relation
to noise and odour which have been
assessed as being required to address
the adverse impacts the operation of the
use of the site has on the immunity of
local residents
and having assessed the application in
very close consultation with
environmental health
and the pros are considered to be
acceptable in principle will not cause
harm to the carriage appearance of the
area
and would not cause harm to the immunity
of existing residents provided that the
mitigation proposes is implemented and
is acceptable in relation to highway
safety access and parking as well as
flood risk and drainage
it's therefore recommended that plan
permission is granted subject to all
interested party parties first entering
into 106 agreement to secure travel plan
monitoring fee as required basis county
council
and
a number of conditions as detailed in
the report as amended by way the updates
i referred to at the beginning
um thank you
thank you
so our first speaker um we do these in a
set order so we have an objective first
that's miss matam's
you'd like to come forward click any
chair i'm so sure one of the members
will help you anywhere you're
comfortable
make yourself comfortable
that's the one
right um we will start the timer as you
begin to speak and then you've got two
minutes precisely from there okay when
you're ready hello my name is lizzie
matham's and i'm a direct neighbour to
kismet kebabs i've come here tonight to
highlight the problems we've been
experiencing from kisma
the noise from the generators fluctuate
24 7.
when they're going at full pill we are
unable to relax in our garden and at
night we have to keep all our windows
closed to listen the constant humming
my son
a nine-year-old um he has adhd and he
has trouble with sleeping
and when he gets hot he can't we can't
open the windows and this causes him to
get stressed and agitated
the pungent smells can be extremely
strong at the front and back of our
property and we are forced to stay
indoors with the windows closed to
prevent the smell from entering our home
this can go on for an hour or all day
any day of the week even sundays
lorries are coming and going at
different times of day mondays to
sundays including bank holidays early
mornings and late in the evenings they
are sometimes left stationary with a
refrigeration running in the entrance to
kismet and on the road outside of our
home waking us up
there's been an increasing number of
seagulls flying over into kismet and
coming back up with pieces of meat they
often squabble and drop the meat into
our garden giving us concern for vermin
problem
thank you for your time
thank you very much welcome
and our next speaker is the applicant mr
devadasan have i got that anywhere near
right sir thank you
again please make yourself comfortable
exactly the same rules um we start the
timer when you begin to speak and you
have precisely two minutes thank you
hi good evening um my name is amir
davidson i'm the ceo for kismet kebabs
but i'm also just an employee as well so
i'm not the owners
um first of all i'd like to apologize
for retrospective planning permission
for this
as well
we're working very very hard with all
the
environmental health offices with the
modern district council to
avoid all these odor and noise controls
to and that's why we we're putting a
mitigation for this planning at the
moment um
waiting for the decision as well um in
that sense
and we want to implement this as soon as
possible so it won't affect
any like neighbors and everything like
that and the environment
um
we are a successful business um we've
been awarded um already twice in a year
on from the british kebab awards um and
we've been in the newspaper a lot we've
been we had our local mp as well um
sat with us at the table for the awards
and we had the mayor ramirez as well
attending the awards which was very
pleasing
to around for the economy around the
malden district council so well
established we've been around for about
14 years
and you know uh it's for me it's
uh coming in and i know how the owners
have
put this in place and i would like to
make sure that i put things in place
correctly so we comply with the district
council um itself
thank you thank you very much okay could
you just turn your microphone off make
sure um you know go back to another seat
uh right members first of all can i
start by introducing our environmental
health officers mr camp
i don't know if you have anything to say
you've been the case officer on this
and looking at the reports and so on yes
to some extent we did um
sorry
sorry you don't have
a contractor um to help with our um
consultation response because it is
quite a complicated and
a detailed um
application um and
what to do with the
um resource constraints within the
department as well but uh but yes also
been involved in the nuisance aspect of
the complaints
against the business as well
thank you but yeah here to answer
questions hopefully technical questions
if needed exactly members so we do have
mr can
but before we get to any proposals or
actual debate can we
sort out any questions or discussions
anyone wants to bring up i think i saw
miss white's hand first followed by
councillor morley um so councillor white
uh thank you madam sherman and um
i've got a few questions um
some of which came up in the meeting the
other day and i just wanted
clarification um
the
if we go back in when i was uh elected
to the council pre when i first got
elected
we had a lot of problems with
enforcement with kismet kebabs
and i know it's not a planning reason
but we went on site in 2012 or 2011
and we were told that the application in
2012 was going to regularize all of
these issues and um that
there wouldn't be any more problems so
fine
so i'm particularly disappointed to be
here again today
um can we go on to slides and can you
show me
which buildings don't have planning
permission
because it looks like there's quite a
few on site although it was 10 years
since i've been there it looks like
there's quite a lot on site that
that weren't there then and i have just
checked and there's no more planning
applications that have been approved in
between
2012 and now
um
through chairman yes so
the um applications being made on the
basis of the buildings a and b were
existing buildings and converted
and it building e1 was an existing
main factory building which had been
extended but the others i think yeah i
think i think that was extended uh with
the last time i was there and this is
another extension that's not got
permission this now these these are um
um there's a front extension and a rear
extension um
both of which have been done um
um
and are subject to the current
application so they don't
is there anything else that's respected
because i don't remember seeing e2 and c
or f
yeah so um
f c e to d
and the sales office building are
retrospective
um
they some of these buildings that the
applicant has said they are they are the
same buildings that were approved in
2012 but they're in a different
place
so you know they haven't got permission
but there there was a permission for
something um
a similar building in a but in a
different part of the site i don't know
that's that's that yeah
that wouldn't fly if it was a house or
anything else so you bought it five
meters in the wrong place you'd knock it
down right okay and and the other
elements the hard standing to the rear
parking area and the fencing yeah did
environmental health check for asbestos
because i do remember when we did one we
did quite a few site visits there to try
and sort the problems out with
councillor archer i went on site two or
three times it was a long time ago and i
haven't been there since
i know there was asbestos found in the
hard standing and i seem to recall there
was a problem with
flooding into a brook at the back i
don't know
what is it flood zone three i can't
quite remember there's something about
the brook at the back which i haven't
seen in the report
um so that's something else i've
got a query with really and do we have
any other sites with opening hours until
11 30 in the vicinity because i know
that you've got mayfair mushrooms
you've got um the other industrial
estate where you've got oh god the trust
building people and i can't remember
what it's called is maple dean i don't
know yet oh dwb that's the one i never
remember their name yeah did it do any
of those until uh 11 30 at night thank
you
yeah yeah i'm sorry
through sherman um
issue of asbestos i'm not aware that has
been any um that doesn't say there
wasn't any but i'm not aware that um
there was a an issue with asbestos but i
mean that's covered by other legislation
so even if there was asbestos there and
there was an issue with asbestos that
wouldn't be a planning
matter it would be
under some health and safety um other
legislation um there isn't there is an
issue with surface water drainage and
the surface water drainage system that
is in place is isn't uh acceptable or
adequate for the um purposes of the site
um but that um during my presentation
and i did um and whether you want to
look at the
slide again but as part of the proposal
um there was a was a flood risk
assessment um submitted it's not flood
risk area
but um because of the size of the site
there was a need for a flood risk
assessment um and that has um through
the these proposals would address any uh
issues with flood risk um or uh surface
water drainage and also the as i said
the um the foul drainage system in
that's in place um isn't the standard we
would normally expect
um at the other sites with opening hours
till um 11 o'clock i'm not aware of any
just to
clarify the
operating hours the um
the operating hours
are until half past five or else being
asked for to half past five monday to
friday with no working on saturday
sundays or bank holidays the additional
hours in the evening beyond half past
five have been requested on the basis
that um cleaning um processes need to be
carried out on a daily basis um because
it's a food production um plant and
everyone
needs to be cleaned to meet um health
and safety or food standards agency
um rules um so
the conditions have been recommended
particularly that in the update um
has
these offices are recommending that up
to 11 o'clock is permitted but on a very
very limited basis and only for cleaning
and only inside the buildings and only
inside building e which is the main
factory building and only on two days a
week so um
it has been reduced quite substantially
from what was originally what appeared
to be originally on the table um but it
is more than what is recommended in the
original agenda because since the agenda
was published they have now provided
some more information to explain why
they need these extra hours and officers
feel that on that basis um it would not
be
it would be
reasonable to allow them um the adequate
time that they say they need to
clean um each day so that they can
produce food for human consumption um in
a safe way thank you
thank you that's what you wanted done uh
yeah i might just come about two things
really one is so building ease the
building that's going to be occupied
till 11 o'clock at night and if i'm
correct
that's the building with the problems
with the fans
um and i seem to recall back in 2012
there was problems with the very
self-same fans that was supposed to be
resolved under that planning application
and yet i'm if i'm writing thinking it's
the same fans might be renewed fans but
it's the same fans that are causing
problems
um and
that building with the fans that's the
problem is the one that's going to be
occupied till cleaning
right and the other thing is i i don't
know i just think
there's a dangerous precedent with
saying it's okay to build what you like
anywhere it doesn't matter if you have
planning or not when
we've made other sites like the one in
all thorn
pull
buildings down
because they weren't built in accordance
with the planning i mean you know as i
support businesses but i do have a few
problems and it's just disappointing
that it was supposed to have been
regularized in 2012 and it's worse than
it was in 2012 theoretically anyway
that's that's enough for me but thank
you thinking science that last one so he
is the one with the problem fan that's
going to be occupied till 11 o'clock at
night thank you right i i've got
counselor morley then councillor keys
but can i just ask as well as
the moving buildings are there any
buildings that are where they used to be
but are being used for a different
purpose that require
just
empty ones that are now in use anything
like that in addition to the ones no
no they're the um all the buildings have
been accounted for if you like um
building e was i say the main factory
building which was there historically
um um and where all the main processing
food processing is carried out and
that's where the cleaning is required um
because of the processes that are
carried on in that building um
so
yeah
yeah thank you so we've got council
morning council keys council of fleming
so oh
and councillor helm is a member of the
council he's here in attendance he's
already asked me before the meeting if
he could speak if you'd mind waiting
till the other members have had their
pop and then we'll um okay councilman
thank you chairman um
i just wanted there's any more
information on scavenging um on the
environmental point of view
with food waste is that going to be
stored
in a sort of a cool building and are
there pest control measures i i can't
really see too much on that
i do know with scavenging
a lot of food waste has to be kept to i
know it's in bins but they're normally
kept in a lockable building as well
um if there's any further information on
that please
please um yeah we just recently received
a complaint about the uh the meat being
dropped by the seagulls in the
neighboring gardens um i have spoken to
mr devadasan about the complaint um i
initially thought it was likely to be
waste storage although we've not visited
the site yet to confirm um he tells me
that it's um as a result of
the factory being washed down and a
small amount of meat coming out um and
they're being issues with existing pest
control measures there's apparently some
deep bird decoys which were lost in high
winds recently and need to be replaced
the birds have apparently got used to
the kind of times that this happens as
you'll see around school playgrounds
with the seagulls and starlings knowing
when the kids are going to be out they
know when there might be a small amount
of meat available and they're coming
down to collect it i've been told that
they're going to renew the the pest
control measures but again we've not
seen that in place yet
but you know
and i have said that we will go and have
a look at the waste storage um at some
point unannounced but so that was
literally in the last couple of days
that we've had those discussions
thank you very much
it may come back yeah just
obviously washing down you can't really
be loading food for human consumption
outside anyway
and as far as i know from my experience
washing down should be done in a
building and it should be in closed
gulleys i would have thought it doesn't
just go outside
um
if you can give me any further i'm just
sure it was closed gullies thank you
that's that's all the information i have
i'm afraid thanks
thank you
right council keys then councillor
fleming and then we'll carry on
um can i go back to the pictures
the
photograph pictures
of the site
correct
uh
go forward too please
another one
another one
another one
another one
oh no sorry must been before that sorry
the like the that's it that top one
there we've got a better picture of that
haven't we that's it there
right
the neighbouring property
is to the left
also the top of the screen correct where
that dangly gardens is then dangly
now you say to the back of that are
redundant agricultural buildings
right
through some of that yes right are they
owned by the kebab man
or dangly gardens no
um i understand they're part of their
property especially with dain lee
they're associated with dangling but
they are within the same ownership
that's mine
someone else's they could be filled full
of chickens or pigs all that with noise
and environmental and bits and pieces
but that's that part and right no that's
all i think john
thank you councillor fleming
thank you chair my question has been
answered actually thank you
excellent thank you um councillor morgan
councillor durham
okay thank you uh thank you
um
firstly um
i note that there was some
other things
a facility for demonstrations
do we know how often those take place i
mean does this mean there's going to be
regular sort of classes or demos taking
place with us so that increased sort of
daily volume of traffic do you know
um through sherman i um there's no
information about how often the
demonstrations occur
i would um perhaps say that that
building is quite small it's got a small
kitchen in it and a like a dining side
dining room size table in it
but in terms of traffic generation i
think that would be quite small in the
context of the the site as as a whole
um
and the parking standards that have been
assessed um include the floor space
within that building as part of the
assessment so any
um
traffic or um parking requirements
generated by that building have have
been taken into account in the wide site
thank you in terms of the access is it
wide enough for two vans to pass what
each other is it coming in the net
through chairman i
i
don't know exactly whether that is
possible or not
all i can say is that highways have not
objected to it and they must be
satisfied that the access is suitable
for the type of vehicles that come and
go from the site and there is
they did originally object um because
they were concerned about um htv's been
not being able to turn within the site
but we following the the receipt of
additional information showing that
htv could turn within the site and enter
and therefore enter and leave the site
in forward gear they they have withdrawn
their objection um
from a layman's point of view it it
it does look quite tight to get two
lorries side by side certainly you get
two cars um
side by side um
where's there's a photo so this is the
photo here um
and then at the entrance you'd probably
get is wide enough to get to lori side
by side but it does narrow um
where that wall is so um
but as i say with the turning circle
turning provision that's been made
within the site highways are satisfied
that that access is suitable for the use
that would be made of it what is already
been made of it
thank you for the
the
objective from the public was obviously
concerned about noise and odour and i
noticed one of the
conditions was in three months of the
date of the planet commission that the
generator is to be removed is that right
um three chairman that was the um
that was what was originally recommended
on the basis that that there it would
have it appeared that then their need
for a generator had been addressed or
overcome through the upgrade of their
electricity supply or their mains
electricity supply um
since the agenda was published the
applicant agent has
queried that and said that they they
would like to be able to keep the
generator because
um but only for use during um
power cuts but no they are very rare but
during power cuts because of the type of
project they have and they the
imperative and the importance of them
being able to keep their food products
frozen and chilled um but they said that
they would only need to use the
generator
before three o'clock
i am each day and that there will be
enough
there there
the containers that they keep their
products in will be insulated enough to
keep that food fresh and safe um until
the following day when they would you
know if the power was still down
they would then be able to not need to
turn the generator back on so
um that that is one of the conditions
that's been
recommended to be changed as part of the
update it was circulated
okay
thank you and finally just a question
really from environmental health
the
the levels of noise and the odors at the
moment are they within sort of legal
standards is it currently
at the moment no which is kind of one of
the reasons we're here we received the
complaints and served abatement notices
in respect to both the the noise and the
odour
in order to comply with those notices um
it became apparent that quite a lot was
the work was going to need to be done
which was probably going to require
planning permission
so we're kind of from an environmental
point of view in a position where we
almost need planning permission for them
to be able to comply with the notices
and going back to going back to
councillor white's question about kind
of
whether or not
you know it's going to be enforced
essentially whilst there is planning
enforcement
we've also got the the added
stick if you like that if they don't
comply with it we can then prosecute
them for failure to comply with the
abandonment notice which is what we'll
probably look to do so
so i'm right in saying we've got a
building that was built without any
planning permission and is causing a
nuisance we're now having to give it to
get planning permission to be able to
cause it to abate the nuisance is that
really where we are
when you put it like that yes it's nice
thank you
sorry um mr johnson would like to come
in at that point
thank you chair um just just just to
clarify the building which is a subject
of most of the noise news is an existing
building
it's the machinery which is operating
within it
it's the machinery which should have
been subject to
noise emission controls so that is the
issue it's not that the building is on
is unauthorized in itself
what's unauthorized on the buildings are
some extensions which mrs matthews
pointed out
so
just to be clear on that
and i just want to just pick up on one
or two
other things that i was sort of hearing
about i mean asbestos was mentioned but
miss matthews pointed out that that's
not under in
planning legislation
um
i was just also just wanted to make
clear um
that we should be mindful of conflating
environmental health issues and we're
talking about issues in terms of
cleaning
through traceable material and that sort
of stuff with the actual planning
permission which is which is what we're
do which is what we're what we're
dealing with here
where there may be breaches in terms of
um
i suppose you know
hygiene regulations i mean that wouldn't
fall on the planet so just just just
just to be mindful of that
um
in terms of the hgv sprinter this is a
site that has had planning permission
from i can't remember in 2000
something yeah
there was that permission in 2012
to actually expand upon the business
they have carried out
development
in which buildings have been placed on
the site not in the position
that has
been approved but in in other positions
um
the building the the place of the
buildings themselves in planning terms
are not illegal as such yeah
and if we were to have considered
enforcement action on any of those
buildings there would have been there
would be an assessment
they may well be okay where they are
yeah it's just that there was approval
for where they were under the 2012
permission so again just to sort of have
these in mind when when we're coming to
a view on on this application thank you
chairman thank you
um could i just let councillor darren
come in first council follow me
yeah well part of what i was going to
say mr johnson has
put to one side but i will come back to
that in a second so fundamentally we're
in a catch-22 situation here aren't we
in that
planning permission is required in order
to rectify
existing
issues
that are relevant planning noise etc
so i i don't know it's an interesting
one i'm not quite sure where to turn on
it but on the subject of i mean our
major alarm bells were rung a bit
earlier about the cleaning down
procedure because you know i do have
quite a lot of experience in commercial
um food preparation areas and you don't
just sweep out the floors into an
outside area where seagulls and rats can
pick food up you sweep it up first and
then wash down i mean they should
anybody that's washing food
of any description to an outside
environment needs to think again
but that isn't a planning consideration
but i'm
slightly concerned
i'm guessing the fans are related to
refrigeration um so clearly they can't
go off
at a set period of
a set time at night because otherwise
the you know the refrigeration fans
would need to be working effectively 24
7 is that correct there are various
various types of fans some of extract
some of the air you know air supply
there are condenser units refrigeration
yeah and and
like your fridge at home sometimes the
condenser will kick in and it will it
will make a noise for a period and then
it will go off again but yeah they they
could go on on and off at any time yeah
large commercial walk-ins and freezers
you know they run for quite a long time
okay
yeah thank you it's an interesting one
thank you
did you say councillor fleming next and
then you missed council stevens of
course it's all right councillor
durham's covered it thank you okay
councillor stevens
thank you chair
um
i think picking up on what we've just
heard about trying to differentiate
between the planning application and the
environmental health because i am
struggling slightly with that
if we were if we were to refuse and the
buildings have to be reverted to
whatever they were like before that did
have permission originally
would that make it less noisy less
smelly
fewer hours
less meaty if that's right expression
i'm just trying to understand what if i
think understanding what would happen if
we refuse it might help me to clarify
that in my head thank you
which of you would like to take that one
i'll perhaps um
partly i'll answer it at least um the
the previous plan permission
um
the council has or the officers have
determined that it was never
implemented and because of the time it's
been since the premiership was granted
they wouldn't be able to use that plan
permission now so if if
the council couldn't require them to
carry out that development um because it
doesn't have plan permission anymore so
i don't think that is a an option um
available
um
but in terms of whether it
would cause
more or less
issues um
that they
in terms of
noise i don't know whether standards
have increased or improved since 20 in
the last 10 years and whether premises
have to comply with more strict
standards nobody shaking his head so um
but at that application
um
at that time there would have been a
need to comply with the relevant
legislation in terms of noise and odour
impact so that they should and and the
scale of that development was was
comparable to what's been proposed now
so i would i would say that the impact
would would be comparable if not
the same and there's there shouldn't
there shouldn't be harm caused
by this proposal subject to mitigation
being imposed or um carried out um
or the previous application they
shouldn't be because
no
officers wouldn't be recommending
approval if they thought there would be
harm caused by this development and we
wouldn't have recommended it last time
if we thought the harm would be caused
by that development but that development
previously did include a number of
um measures and um
mitigation and no measures to ensure
that noise and odor and were not were
not would not be an issue provided to
carry that development in accordance
with the details that they'd submitted
and did that answer your question
it does thank you so i think um if we
were to refuse
what would what would have to happen if
we were to say no to this please
um chairman uh i think um it's been
partly answered already um so if planned
parenthood was refused and all the
development that we're considering
tonight would be unauthorized and
doesn't have planning permission so
there would be um from a planning point
of view the planning enforcement offices
would then have to take the matter up
and take it forward and assess whether
um it was expedient to take enforcement
action um and if it was what that action
would be um it wouldn't necessarily be
um require them to take all those
buildings down that they haven't had
permission for because there would need
to there need to be some
harm caused by what's there and for to
justify that action being taken
um
there's separate enforcement issues in
terms of environmental health which
environment health will go away and
consider um
but um
that's particularly on the on the basis
that um
well i suppose it depends what the
reasons for refusal are as well um if
the reasons for refusal are technical
reasons um
um or whether it would that be quite
different to if you're refusing plan
permission from the principle of it or
that the harm the character and
appearance harm that it no the officers
don't think it causes but if if that was
the reason for refusal um but that would
be a matter that would need to be
considered separately and because
refused planned permission wouldn't
necessarily mean that enforcement action
would be taken um and it wouldn't
necessarily mean that if enforcement
action was taken that would be requiring
the site to revert back to how it was
in 2012 before any of this development
was carried out but that's a decision or
an assessment to be made
later on and shouldn't really affect
how this application is decided as a
planning application
um because it should be decided to come
in on it on its own merits i think
michael might want to thank you yes i've
got hands up everywhere but i've got a
very quick question so building e the
factory building
has permission both to be there and to
be a factory built
am i right have i got have i grasped
that yeah
most of it mostly most of the most
extensions the original yes mostly most
of what's there is um
um
uh is authorized
is not in breach of planning okay
so the fact of the food production in
that building or at least part of it
that's that's an established fact and it
has permission
yes that that site has got quite a long
history of food and animal production
yeah i've got two members but can i let
mr johnson come in for a moment thank
you thank you chairman it was really
just going to pick up on on the
enforcement element
most of which have been answered by
mrs matthews uh but in terms of the
exercise
um
if we were uh dealing with a refusal of
planning permission and
the possibility of enforcement action
um
what would need to be removed um
for us to feel that the operation of the
site would be acceptable
uh there would be an exercise we'd have
to carry out we'd have to go back to
suppose first principles you know what
was on the site before any unauthorized
development was take place what was the
scale of the operations there
with for example the additional
buildings and the extensions has that
resulted in an intensification of the
development has the intensification in
itself given rise to
some of the issues which are sought to
be mitigated
under what the application we're dealing
with today
it's that sort of exercise that we would
have to carry out the baseline is that
there is a business there is and there
is an operation there yeah
um
and so so something can go on there the
other question is can that something be
controlled if some of these unauthorized
elements were taken away you know um
it's it's it's going to be quite
complicated
in the applicant's defense on any on any
uh
on any refusal
it would be that these are measures
which have been considered
uh under discussion with environmental
health the regulatory body in terms of
some of those uh issues odor noise
um you know there's been objections from
the highway authority
these are things that we just have to
bear in mind yeah and their defense
would be that this application must have
sought to address some of these issues
yeah
so that's what's going to be balanced
you know we have to balance up and i
think that may be some of what counted
down we're saying the chicken and the
egg
quite so thank you um council fleming
then councillor dharam thank you
question for miss matthews or mr johnson
um
the noise mitigation and the odor
control measures those on their own do
they need planning permission and if no
why can they not be carried out
beforehand
and then if the application's deferred
and then we're we're looking
a new application we'd be looking at
measures already installed and that
would take away the chicken and the egg
situation we're in at the moment
um yeah through you chairman um
some of the measures could be carried
out certainly any of those that relate
to
any works or
um
what's to carry out inside the buildings
but um any anything that would
materially alter the external appearance
of the buildings um
what we're talking about the um
the original main building um would need
plan permission and so if they needed to
put a
new ducting on the roof for example um
that would need plan permission or if
they needed to i think quite a lot of
the mitigation measures are enclosing
existing air conditioning units with an
acoustic
cover um
that
that would need plan permission because
it changes the appearance of the
building orbit you could argue one
one air conditioning unit being enclosed
probably not but because of the numbers
um it would overall i think
um
that's perhaps an easier question answer
for the main building but for the other
buildings
the buildings themselves don't have plan
permission
um so it's the totality of the building
and the um
the mitigation that they need to put on
or include within the within the
building or attached to the building um
that needs plan permission so they don't
need plan permission in their own right
um but the building with those
mitigation messages particularly those
that go on the outside of the building
do
there's some very straightforward
questions that we need to understand i
think here
so from what mrs matthews has just said
the company
and we're very
in mind these are retrospective which is
never a good thing
so this company cannot really do
anything significant to improve existing
noise and smell
issues if this
planning application is refused is that
correct mrs matthews
through not lawfully no
lawfully right so they we so if we don't
if we don't
grant this
the noise and the smell issue will
remain
a partial answer i suspect to counsel
oh sorry my man's gone stevens sorry my
pound's gone completely blank
another outcome would be an appeal
against refusal and i suspect an
inspector would look back at the
planning history to see that a lot of
this was
granted
previously and not carried out so there
would there is actually some significant
planning history here
so i i
as i said we have been backed into a
situation
here
by the fact that it's retrospective and
by the fact that
um
in order to improve the current
environmental situation
we have to grant this planning
permission and i'm not very comfortable
with it
i've got mr johnson but ca and i'm also
going to cancel this flight
but can i stick my neck out with a
question so will
if this planning permission doesn't come
about one way or another and the
nuisance continues
does there come a point where
environmental health actually shuts down
some part of the process in order to
solve the problem with the noise and the
order
it's is that
part of the future
shutting down a business well i didn't
say a whole business
process
you must take some action presumably
what sort of action would you take it so
action that we can action that we can
take in in respect of failing to comply
with an abatement notice the options
really are to prosecute
or
you can
in some circumstances carryout works in
default now the council is not going to
go in and spend
thousands of pounds trying to remedy
this so in this instance it's not really
an option so um it's yeah that's the
really the only option available to us
and prosecuting them in itself doesn't
solve the noise nuisance problem there
might be a hefty financial penalty or
that was the next question so it's fine
but nothing changes presumably
um
i'm not trying to put words in your
mouth i'm just trying to find out what
what happens next yeah we don't agree
this
we are a planning inspector yeah i mean
you
you could you could look at injunctions
and things as well but that's obviously
an entirely different um
can i come back on on on the point
related to my questions just for um
just before mr johnson and that's
completely gone out my head so um
there's too many things whizzing around
just let mr johnson go mr johnson yeah
please do so oh no the point i was going
to make is that if gru this will only
work
if the work is carried out in accordance
with the planning approval
and
that's a big well that's only a
two-letter word it's a big word it's a
very big word and my question sorry
before anyone else is this is all
enforceable
and i don't mean is it
theoretically enforceable i mean can we
actually
enforce it things like generators
running only when there's a power cut
right mr johnson
yeah thank you jim um
i mean some of what i was going to say
was i've been sort of picked up because
i was going to touch on the
environmental health element
in terms of if planning permission is
refused there are the environmental
health powers but i think as david even
mentioned to me at some point a defense
for them would be that you know they
tried you know the best practical means
possible yeah which involves getting
planning permission yeah and the local
authority have turned it down yeah so
that's a defense in terms of you know
them
under any prosecution
um
you know
again you know david sort of said that
how far are you going to go in terms of
i don't know cracking them over the back
because they've you know they've been
naughty yeah
you know there's a financial implication
in terms of how you'd be going about
trying to do that yeah
um
it's yeah it it it's quite a difficult
situation but then just to pick up on an
easy question that was mentioned in
terms of the enforceability
we have conditions in place which are
quite
rigid now and they're quite detailed to
the various elements which is under con
under consideration here
um
you know the
the hours of operation
um you know things which are quite
tangible things in which we can pick up
on things in terms of the mitigation and
the maintenance and the ongoing
maintenance around the fans and the odor
control which also from a planning point
of view was quite a significant issue
the whole discharging
basically on the boundary you know and
how is that to be mitigated and managed
in the long term
these are things that if planning
permissions refused
um
then we'll be in a difficult position
yeah we'd have to move to
it possibly enforcement but then that
takes us back to what's the base
position that the site can operate under
thank you chairman thank you councillor
white did you want uh thank you i've
just got two things really i mean this
is a nonsense this fan how big is this
fan that goes out into the garden of
dain lee which is the main reason we're
here how big is this fan
that big that big
okay now we run yeah
okay well we run a lot of commercial
buildings we don't do food but we have a
lot of commercial buildings we have fans
and some other farmers do as well that
can be up to 30 foot wide 40 foot wide
and you know what we do with them
we vent them do you know you can vent
them around corners
so why aren't we removing that fan
why aren't we enforcing it and getting
planning in to put a vent in that goes
around the corner and chucks the fumes
and the smell and everything else out
into their own yard why is there even a
fan
into a residential garden
um i suspect i can answer that well
yeah okay
look at the application
they can't do
the mitigation works because of the
planning well you don't need planning to
move an internal vent
you know that's not planning you could
do that anyhow and it's not even
expensive it's aluminium
or whatever it's made of it's metal
tubes and they come in little bits and
you sort of stick them together and
galvanize there we go and they go around
corners and you can put them where you
want you do
so
why why are we saying that that's the
one thing i did get a little bit uh
upset when i just heard this it's
ridiculous and how long has this noise
problem been going on a month
two months a year two years ten years
three years four five
i can't ask you to speak again mrs
matins but could you stick a few fingers
up and give us a clue
more than ten minutes more than ten
years okay
so so this same fan has been a problem
for more than 10 years
and the other thing i want to ask is in
the 2012 planning permission which
wasn't implemented there was meant to be
now i don't know what it was there was a
problem because
they built the bond so close on the
boundary there was a problem with
getting there and at the time there
weren't any trees so when we did the
site visit you could see the back of the
barns and it was really clear but i
haven't been there since and there was
supposed to be some great big acoustic
fence and there was supposed to be all
sorts of other things put up
um and i think they either didn't go up
or they didn't work or they gave up um
and i just think
why i mean i think we should have a site
meeting why are we even considering a
fan
discharging into a garden a residential
garden when it's really simple to move
it and you don't need planning
i mean because i think if we had this
one problem solved
for me it would make the rest of the
application an awful lot more palatable
but the
the
there must be protections for everybody
and i think the amenity for the
residents has got to be up there we
can't just ignore what they're going
through and hope it gets done what i
just don't understand one earth there's
a fan there why why put a fan on a
massive site like that into the
next-door neighbor's garden
i'm sorry i can't let any um you know we
do have procedures it is the
constitution and i can't let any members
of the public speak again on this
application um counsel can i come back
yes okay um
yes um
there's two points i wanted to make one
was yes
you could you know that that that plan
could have been put in a much
better position and and being able to
vent merrily without causing harm to the
neighbor if it was in a different
position on the other side of the
building example um
that said
environmental health the specialists
have advised that with mitigation that
is proposed that that fan would not
cause
on to the immunity of the neighbours
um so we know as planning offices we're
not specialists so
we would take their advice
i know if you might come back in 2012 we
were told exactly the same thing exactly
word for
nobody's
word
the law sorry dude that's fine um and
the other
thing i was going to
mention that if this issue came up um i
have very recently whether it was today
or yesterday even um
that the applicant has said that they
they would be if no it'd have to be
required by condition but if that was
the real sticking point then they would
be prepared to move that vent to
somewhere else that isn't inventing out
onto the neighbor
um so
[Music]
the thing is sorry i will try and get to
everyone the thing is that both the
planning offices and the environment
have health offices can only operate
within the law so you know if
if what's proposed meets the standard
you can't make someone be less unable
unfortunately
i think you should be able to that's my
own feeling but we actually
can't i mean it seems quite reasonable
to me that anyone running something like
that and upsetting their neighbours
could
deal with it
but we can't as far as i can tell within
the statutes we've got make them yeah
if i might come back this was a this was
above the legal
noise level this wasn't just a nuisance
this was completely
illegal and against all the health codes
i know but we're talking about after the
mitigation right i've got councillor
dharam council for fleming councillor
morgan
um
we've got to reach some sort of
conclusion at some point even if it's
you mentioned a site visit council miss
white the members can
determine to defer for a site visit
i'm in your hands man sorry chad i was
going to make a proposal to defer this
particularly when reading condition 21
about the existing generator shall not
be used from the first of august but
presumably because the
substation is being upgraded by uk power
network so i personally feel that
it would be better to defer this
application until we can all go on a
site visit
we can be assured at a later date that
the substation is up and running and the
generator is not going to cause any
further nuisance and it has been removed
from the site so at least we are
sort of curing one of the problems we
haven't got to the smell but at least
the noise uh we could be partially
satisfied with that
do i have a second
second well with calcium
sit that hand up to second
okay sorry um three chairman um i did
mention earlier that they they the
proposal is to keep the generator
on site for emergencies power cuts
and that is that so that condition that
was
included and the original papers has
been changed and the update so it can
they can keep it but
as an officer recommended they can keep
it but only to be used in emergencies
and not after three o'clock in the
afternoon
can i come back to so if i make my
proposal is then that we do defer until
the substation is uh installed which is
what within three to five weeks time
and at a later date we could then hear
from the neighbors to understand whether
the generator is still being used
um i think it's reasonable that it's
allowed there for power cuts
um but we could hear testimony from the
neighbors at that point
yeah thank you
sorry but
okay right i've got councillors out i
mean that that's a proposal we've yet to
even think about having a debate so
we're not going to jump to any
conclusion on that um mr johnson you
wanted to come in there
thank you chairman um
i i just feel very uncomfortable the
decisions with members of course but i
just feel pretty uncomfortable for us to
wait for
um
a
third part of that free undertaker
carrying out works
on a site which is subject of a planning
application for us to consider i mean if
there was a dla for example with uk
power network in finishing those works
these things happen how far do we wait
do we wait three months do we make six
months do you know um
that would be unreasonable grounds for
us to delay determining this application
and on any appeal if that be the case
for non-determination there could be a
cost application
thank you chairman yeah i was going to
say this this would presuppose that an
agreement not to appeal on
non-determination i mean i personally
could be up for a site visit but not at
some
potentially undetermined point in the
future
right i've got councillor dharam and
councillor morgan
chairman it's just not realistic to
defer until a statutory undertaker
because we all know what they're like
you know three weeks never it's just not
going to happen and we're going to get
into trouble and chairman i mean i i
hearing what mrs matthews said i i was
minded to
to table a proposal to
grant planning permission
provided there is a condition to move
what i assume is an extract fan rather
than the cooling fan is that correct
is this the one closest to daily would
you know there's so many uh yes that's
an extra strap
on the condition that that extract
from that uh vent
is moved to the other elevation
which would solve
the smell problem
certainly could but we do have a
proposal that's duly
councillor morgan
council helm is waiting very patiently
he did say he'd like to be able to speak
and i will obviously let him because
he's already asked me counselor morgan
uh yeah it's just a really question from
mr johnson so whether with regards to
the extractor fan would moving that or
ducting that could that be made some
part of a unilateral undertaking on the
part of the applicant
i don't think we need to go as far as
unilateral undertaking a condition um
would be suffice
um
um the details of which could would need
to be agreed with us i think we're quite
clear this is that matter we have
actually discussed ourselves um on what
the extract and fan should do where it
should go
um to assist in mitigating i mean i
think that's a fairly straightforward
matter what's been
what's been encouraging is that the
exactly applicant is prepared to do that
um if that be the wishes of the uh
committee and it'd be a determining
factor in the resolution of this
application
thank you chairman
okay
okay
quickly
please
yeah just to say i mean i do think a
slight visit would be useful see how
many fans open out there and as for the
smell i drove home from a council
meeting last week and i don't know what
night it was it was dark so it was
obviously quite late
and the smell was unbelievable it was
cooking meat it wasn't raw meat and it
wasn't moldy meat it wasn't only gone
off it was cooked meat and i could smell
it from before where dwb was
right up until that tea junction so that
isn't just a case of a little fan i mean
i don't know there must be ways of
mitigating it i don't know um but you
know i know for me i think site visit
would be interesting to see can these
things be vented is it impossible you
know where are we and and how far into
the garden do they go
you know
yeah and i accept what councilor white
has said but
unfortunately food production facilities
produce
a smell wherever they are
so
it is the duty to
move it and
reduce it as much as possible anybody
that drives through with them can smell
the malt all across
whitman everybody it is i mean you can
smell it on the a12 as you drive along
the a-12 i used to work in banbury where
general foods was located and as you
drove through banbury the entire the
entire town of banbury you could tell
whether general foods were making nest
cafe coffee or birds custard because the
whole town smelt of it that's not to say
that this is not important but you know
life is
you know food production will inevitably
produce
a smell it's the we have to mitigate it
and make sure it isn't causing an undue
nuisance and an extract into somebody's
garden or direction of their house is
unreasonable but it doesn't matter what
we do
where it goes to if the wind is going
the wrong direction
the smell from this plant is going to
is going to be there the only way of
stopping the smell is to close the plant
down which is not nothing we we can't do
it
so it doesn't say it doesn't matter
where we put that vent
there will still be odor but we have to
make sure that it's minimized in terms
of nuisance for the for the neighbors as
far as possible hence my um proposal
it's just to say that with the smell the
factory wasn't even supposed to be
operating then it was supposed to have
shut up half past five and it was
probably almost nine ten o'clock i don't
know yeah point point taken well i don't
know how about how long the venting
carries on right paul councillor hell
you've sat there all this time would you
would you like to
thank you madam chairman i'm not a
member of this committee
i live in lexington across the road but
i spoke to simon the business i conduct
is not the same as
their business so i can speak
so when you say do you mean the
monitoring officer
simon
so it's not related anyway so i can
speak
i cleared that with him several months
ago
regarding this smell
and noise from fans i've been in the
garden it is real really real and it's
been there for 10 years
and for our
environmental health have been informed
they know about it
i know enforcement has been stretched at
the moment
but something ought to be done about
this why should they live like that
now miraculously the seagulls have
disappeared
the last few months we've had
100 seagulls in the field opposite
now they've disappeared so obviously
what you said did something about it
um
i know
highways have proved their entrance
but should they be backing into their
entrance
could they backing be backing down the
road because they're overshot and back
in
i don't think that's quite right is that
we've had several near misses we've had
delia fatality at the bridge just down
the road where the dust cart went over
motorcyclists and several other
accidents there
so there is speed in this area
and i don't want actually no one of the
lorries did back into a car when it was
backing up
so there's a real problem there
um and i've had them come in tomorrow
bother me
drive in but because we've got an
automatic gate they can't turn around so
what they've done in the middle of the
night back out without any banks or
anything
so i know there's nothing to do with
planning
nothing to do with planning i agree with
that
but i i really think something oh the
history of the site
they used to kill persons the little
chickens
years ago
and that went up to london to harrods
and everything else and then it was sold
off to the kebab people they came in
um
and another history lesson
the council took action against old mr
bonson because he had four ornamental
little chickens because they were
crowing
and he ended up going to court and he
had to put them down
and he was 80 odd
and he didn't last much longer after
that so that's another lesson for the
council enforcement thank you
yeah i hear what you're saying counts at
home but with the best will in the world
the applicant cannot control what
happens on the highway i know that i
know that the people's drivers
thank thank you chairman uh just to
point out that um
the app the application does include a
turning point within it and the whole
purpose for that is to help mitigate
some of these highway issues
um for the lorries to drive in and out
in forward gear
um
i don't know if there's any more
information you can add to that mrs
mattis but if we can bring up that
drawing that actually shows that that
would mitigate
the issues in terms of the
heavy goods vehicles
apologies for the drawing yeah
but it looks better on there on the
laptop um good
so the tiny area
is clearer picture is in here so lawyers
will come in here they'll come in here
and then reverse here and then be able
to go out and forward gear and that
that's what that
flapping movement there is is showing
um but not that clearly sorry about that
these are large vehicles they are
presumably suitably qualified drivers
and able to do that that's fun
and this is obviously your counselor
my question is if that's we've been
looking at this on google earth
if those lorries are supposed to be
reversing around that how low are those
canopies that stick out because my lorry
is 14 and a half feet high
and i don't think that would get round
there with those canopies
fortunately i suspect that's not a
decision we could make highways are
happy they're the statutory authority
and that's where we are
but
we do have a proposal on the table
unless unless it is withdrawn
thank you chair um i'll so i'll withdraw
that amendment and then uh make a
proposal that we um
defer so that we can all go on a site
visit
do i have a second off
well it wasn't valid until we did
something about that one
and yours is that we
let's have it
is it only the one and can we
legitimately
not not just the ones facing into the
garden but anything on that motivation
is that there is
this is the um the bottom one is the
elevation which faces
dangly um so extraction unit g1
is is the unit that i understand it
causes them the you know the smells and
um particularly smells and that one is
directly next to their rear garden
um there is a compressor d1 that but
that's on the return wall and that that
is actually positioned beyond their rear
garden it's more and more
and that's next to the disused farm
buildings referred to and there is
a um
unit on the roof
and you can see from this elevation and
so that's looking at the factory from
from northern road so that's the
position of the air conditioning unit
close to the
ridge and in terms of distance from the
boundary that gives you some idea about
how far
and my understanding is it is this unit
g1 which is the the main cause of
a lot if not almost all of the um
complaints so and and that is the one
that the applicant has offered to
relocate and vent out on a more
appropriate um position and i'm not sure
where it'd be best located and as
planning officers i would revert to
environmental health to tell me where is
the best least
most neighborly place for it to go and
there may be some limitations internally
about there may be some limits on
exactly where it could go potentially
but um but yeah that's the offer
i think we should probably delegate the
the actual details of that condition
that would be correct
and just just to clarify on that point
because i did raise this when the
application came in milton house isn't
shown with it as within the ownership or
control of the applicant
this i um and
so as far as this application is
concerned that that property is outside
the application site and not within the
blue line um
so yeah
okay right for the sake of clarity miss
bird are you happy with what our
proposal actually is
counselor durham's proposal of course
oh yes chairman
is proposing that the grant provision
for the additional petition
and details of which will be delegated
to officers
okay
um anyone else have anything further
to say and now we have a proposal now we
debate it there's possibly not a lot
left to say but if that if that proposal
fails then i'd like to propose secondary
that we'd have a site visit and then
make a decision after the site visit do
a deferral so you know we've got the two
in there that's
that's a very fair
i'm no i'm not quite sure yes i
did think i was quite keen on that idea
but
anyway we have a proposal can we please
have a show of hands in favor council of
durham's proposal to approve subject to
the deferred condition right what have
we got one two three four
okay those against
one two three abstentions
okay so that has
passed
with that condition
gentlemen i would ask or implore mr
johnson and his enforcement team to be
right on this with that
in the last 12 years i'll steady on this
white please no i'm not not having that
that's right
okay
moving on so that is it's agreed with
that extra condition and
a special request to mr johnson and his
team
um yes
right item six which was carl carl house
and wicked bishops has been withdrawn
item seven is our next
next planning application it's albany
orchards in wood and water
and there's a member's update as i've
already said and we do have the agent to
speak after the president thank you of
course
right yes
thank you chairman
the application is for a new driveway
from an existing access which would lead
towards the front of the house
the existing driveway
driveway will remain the same
this is the application site the
proposed new access and the driveways to
the east dwelling
and would connect to the existing
driveway
so here is the existing and here is the
proposed
here is the block plan
shows proposed and the remaining
the existing to remain
here the site pho here is a site photo
this photo was taken on the
existing driveway facing the proposed
access
um so this is where the
proposed
access is facing the dwelling
the existing access and then a google
image of the existing access from the
highway
the proposed access from the inside the
site
and the proposed access from the outside
facing the west and face knee
and then the views from the proposed
access from within the site so there's
the east and then there's the north and
you've seen the west which is facing the
dwelling
and that's it
thank
you this application's up for refusal as
it is considered that the proposed
development would introduce a form of
development into the rural area which
would which by reason of its very nature
design and location would be an alien
and urbanizing feature and as such
visually intrusive into the character of
local landscape thank you chairman thank
you
all right the agent speak miss brown
please come forward i'm sorry we've had
to wait so long but i'm sure you
understand
oh we are
i i know you know the rules but for
everyone's cycle say it again you've got
two minutes from when you begin
thank you albany orchards is an
established country house that was built
as a replacement dwelling following a
planning approval given in 2006.
it's the carefully crafted building that
has matured and gently settled into its
bucolic setting over the last 15 years
further additions to the site have
served to build on this quality and it
is an asset to wooden walter
an application was made for new driveway
from an existing access on london road
in 2011. this was refused based on the
potential domestication of agricultural
land and the impact as viewed from the
road
at the time of this application
hedgerows had not been established and
the field was more far more visible from
the highway
whilst the house retains full permitted
demand development rights the applicant
is happy for conditions to be attached
to any approval for the driveway to
prevent any further development within
the agricultural land adjacent to it
in the last 11 years the hedgerows along
the road become established and the
visibility of the field from london road
and oak farm road has become
significantly reduced
ongoing residential development to the
east of oak farm road opposite the site
has changed the character of the setting
such that the field is now between
dwellings rather than open countryside
whilst there are the obvious arguments
relating to the change of use and loss
of agricultural land it should be noted
that the field has been used as an
unbounded extension to the garden of the
house for over 15 years
this application a just sweep of the
proposed driveway so that it is tucked
more closely behind the hedge the red
line of the application is immediately
on the edge of this driveway access and
therefore prevents any other areas of
the field being coming becoming seen as
domestic cartilage preventing the
precipitation of development in this
area in relation to the house
the new driveway entry point will also
create a safer access to the house from
london road the current entrance
driveway is on a change in angle in the
road which limits visibility in both
directions
the new entrance ray is on a straight
stretch which will make exit from the
site onto the highway safer for the
owners of the house
thank you
that's fine we've got councillor down
first
yeah chairman i called this in um
and um
for a couple of reasons and and members
have been around a while but
councillor white will remember well
possibly um when this came for us before
um
i was actually very vociferous in
opposition to it but to the previous
design
the previous design sort of snaped down
the middle in a rather ostentatious
manner
and
as you drove up from malden road which
from the right hand side there you you
would have seen it literally
dominate up to the front of the house
this application however
is different for two reasons a that it
keeps to the hedge line
and also since that time the hedges and
and if you you can actually see them if
we can go back to the photographs
yeah that one shows it very well and
then previous one i think showing the
gate there
that the hedges are now so big and i
drive past this every day and i i
my concern was as you come up from
malden previously
you could see the whole field now you
can't and actually i doubt
that we would be over anybody on that
you know
would be able to
to see it because of the
the growth that's been in in those
hedges
um
i know the officers are concerned that
the hedges aren't protected um and i
don't know if there's a way
around that certainly you know if the
hedges were cut back
then
clearly then we're going to have more of
more of a visual impact but certainly
not to the extent that it would have
been on the previous
previous application which was said
snaked right down the middle of that
field
in respect of the making it a safer um
a safer place to
access actually yes because there is a
much better visual
um
visibility both sides from that
particular thing so um as i said whereas
i was previously
extremely against it as i said the the
site has changed significantly and i now
don't have
any reasonable reason to object to this
the the agent also mentioned uh and it's
a shame there aren't photographs of the
the buildings on the eastern side on on
the junction
which are if an absolute
appalling eyesore i see the
smiles from the officer she uh
clearly doesn't disagree
um
and you know that has changed the whole
visual um impact of that entire area so
chairman that's why i called it in i i
actually think that that
this won't cause
significant um
visual intrusion
um as i said you know i don't think you
will actually see the road and i'm very
pleased to see that the red lines have
been drawn because
as we've heard that means that the the
ground either side
um won't be developed and won't have
things like garden paraphernalia on it
etc which currently currently prohibited
so that those are my reasons and
in saying that i would be happy um if
there's a second of to
propose uh that this
is granted
um you know as i said if there is a
possibility to condition the retention
of the hedges
at a similar height it's not fair to say
to somebody they can't trim it to make
it look nice but i wouldn't want to see
the height of them reduced
and that that would be my proposal chain
right and that includes your reason for
approval which overcomes this reason for
refusal once it probably covers it
okay
mr johnson can we protect the hedges and
in any case you can only protect any of
that soft landscaping for five years
but can we protect the hedges ultimately
um
then thank you chairman uh i must admit
i i'm not an expert on sort of hetero
it's outside of the application site
so that's the no but in terms of this
application this is a fundamental thing
it's not something that we can employ a
particular controller but what i did
want to just add as well is um that
um there are there are a few things in
the application where there's been some
assertions that um the the the land is
residential in itself let's just talk
about driveway the whole of the land
that was clearly not the case in 2012
and there's been no evidence that is
anything other than agricultural land
yeah
the other thing is in terms of in terms
of the detail of what would be provided
and and and i'll just sort of draw a
members attention to the to the frontage
yeah
um it would have to be designed to
highway standards um and if we if we go
to a photograph so uh jade if you can go
to photograph showing
uh yeah there's a right um
we you know we've got a verge there
um it may not be quite evident here but
there's actually a dip in the verge
um so the verge itself does um
recede downwards towards the site from
the edge of the road
uh for obvious reasons um
that area to to provide an appropriate
ingress and egress for the car would
have to be built up
we're also talking about visibility
splays here while not set out in the
application
um
there
there has there has been a a a a late um
consultation response from highway
setting out the usual standard
conditions
if um
you know this application were to be
provided and that would have to satisfy
highway standards so in terms of the
intrusion into the street it's not
rolling over you know a bit of verge as
it stands there will be there will be
development
um to highlight the fact that there is
this access there any gates that will be
provided would have to be set back six
meters from the boundary again as as is
per standard so really we don't have the
detail in front of us of what would be
the finished development if it were to
comply with highway standards thank you
chairman
sean can i come back on that please
in terms of visibility you can see from
from there you've got a really good
visibility both sides up up and down the
road the existing entrances are actually
on the brow of a hill so you only got
limited visibility one way i totally
accept what mr johnson has said and and
clearly that would be a condition that
you know county council
set their uh design standards for the
entrance on and off the the highway um
like a bound surface etc and and i'm
absolutely sure that the applicant would
do that it would be absolute madness not
to have a um
to complete the road and i'm glad to see
it's not tarmac it's going to be a a
gravel drive
and and to have a highways compliant and
a bell mouth onto the onto the main road
i don't see that as being an issue at
all and as i said in terms of visual
intrusion
a bell mouth there is absolutely nothing
in comparison to the huge bell mouth
that's just been created 400 yards down
the road which i suggest next time
somebody's going along there go and have
a look at it
that's all thank you councillor keys
councillor white and councillor morgan
thank you for cheering them council
downs took a bit of um
my thunder but i don't know as well as
castle down because i don't go by every
day but i work for the demolition
company that knocked the old house down
and i low loaded the machinery in there
and this entrance is 100 percent better
than the entrance i was trying to get
that blooming lorry in the 360s on and
the visual impact
up the top was councilman said it's a
bravo hill it was a nightmare trying to
get the diggers in and out of there and
the muck away and this down the road i
presume there's a dot dip there because
that's a filled in ditch as it goes
we're done yeah yeah so yeah with
today's technology they can sort out
that so yeah that's all right and i
think this is definitely a lot better it
entrance and access to the property
okay councilman's
yeah thank you well unlike the last
application i don't think there's any
harm to this one
um i don't think there's any harmful
immunity i don't think there's any half
of the countryside um and actually i
voted for it the last time around
because i didn't have a problem with it
last time around either i thought it was
a lovely driveway i'd like a driveway
like that but i don't mind um with the
hedges because it's like agricultural
land they are automatically protected by
the hedgerow order
and no part of them can be removed
without a specific application to remove
the hedgerow under the hedro act
um so they might have to do another one
of those and but that doesn't really
that doesn't affect this application and
i'm happy to support um councillor
durham's proposal um pending that they
do take the um correct permission
to um comply with the hedgerow act
okay councilman morgan
yeah i think you understand
i understand the reason for uh refusal
is because you the the belief or the
that the land over which this driveway
is to be built is agricultural
is that right
whereas as i understand it from the
agent it's actually been used as part of
the domestic
whether
more than 10 years so therefore it would
be open to the applicant to make an
application for a certificate of lawful
users
and if they did so presumably that
objection would disappear
in terms of a
driveway
counselor
mr johnson
i can just fill in chairman just very
quickly with you and your indulgence yes
um as i said i know i do just around the
corner from this drive past it every day
yes technically it is agricultural land
it was agricultural land before but i
can vouch for the fact that it's been
closely moaned for since the house was
built which is not technically
that's actually a pretty obvious
photograph and in fact
in in the summer um
it has beautiful straight lines up and
down it uh that that actually put
wimbledon to shame so yeah whether or
not that is necessarily agricultural um
it's not being agricultural for goodness
knows how long um
and but yeah
it's been closely known for
as long as the house has been there
that's a case of lawful use isn't it
mr johnson thanks chairman i mean it was
really just a point of clarification in
terms of the reasons for refusals
um
i mean it set out section a in in in the
report there and it's around the form of
development in the rural area by reason
of its nature alien urbanizing future
etc etc
um
[Music]
in terms of the site
as or the claim for it being residential
they would have to go through formal
processes and demonstrate that but then
that would be for them to do yeah
and make the usual arguments um as it
stands and
unless otherwise you know it's
agricultural land and i do take all the
points that has been moan and all the
rest of it yeah but the designation
still stands
um i think that those were the oh right
now that i just thought were members
like you know
minded to approve the application they
were obviously their standard condition
that but there's the additional three
conditions which have been suggested by
the highways authority
thank
you can i can i ask a question about i
was assuming the lawful use of
agricultural land what what is the full
back position of the farmer
wanting to put a track across this land
what permission does does a farmer need
to put a track across an agricultural
field
yeah i mean i mean what we have in front
of us is a
as a formalized yeah truck yeah and and
there's a red line around it to
incorporate it into the cartilage as
such yeah yeah i mean a farmer's
tracking something completely different
which i do understand yeah i appreciate
that but i just wanted to
find out the answer to the question
sorry councillor morgan yeah well that's
really going on from that i mean i i
appreciate the europe
applying the the the print the planning
principle because it is agricultural
land but i i really think that there's
there's an element of subjective
judgment going here
how you can say that by its very natured
design and location would be an alien
and urbanizing feature when it's a
driveway i'm afraid i don't just simply
don't see that
and a gravel drive without you um
i'm sorry it's it's it's after such a
long meeting it's escaped my memory what
what is the surface of this intended
to be this is gravel okay
and the width of the red sight line is
the width of the proposed gravel and no
more
okay
well we do have a proposal from oh sorry
counselor stephen i'm sorry we will sit
so far away i hadn't got the lurgy i had
a test the other day
sorry counselor stevens i do apologize
it's fine thank you chair um it's not
just a drive though is it it's a gate as
well and i haven't seen any picture of
what this gate would look like and i
think we've got a bit of a plague around
in the countryside of
gold tipped gates and very sort of
gates that look like they should be in
mayfair or something like that have we
got
certain sorry i didn't hear you
any have we got any information and
pictures of what the gates will look
like and the brick piers beside them
because i think that's what could be
urbanizing it's not the drive itself
that fusses me very much but i don't
want to see more gold tip gates in very
modern
brick piers thank you
yeah
thank you chairman i mean i would just i
mean that's actually an interesting
point um that we'd gone on the line of
refusal without thinking about obviously
the proposal in in that respect
but the the incorporation of that land
within the residential cartilage as
tightly defined as it is and we can see
it also splits out onto the verge
um
could mean where the application to be
approved uh
engage permitted development rights
and permitted development rights for
fences set
um
a certain distance behind the interface
with the public highway could mean
something to a height of at least two
meters
of any material
which is where your
brick piers and your
gold
topped gates can come in without any
control
so again if if members are minor to
approve it then this is probably prudent
to exercise some condition to manage any
detail in that respect
kevin i i mean i'm trying to think what
the gate is like at the other end
you know the majority of large
properties
in the in the parish have
they are yeah so i suspect it will be
similar to that you know inevitably for
obvious reasons the majority of gates
on the large properties
here and elsewhere are electric
and clearly
the distance from the house would mean
that that would be
necessary
though i i don't think that it's
certainly
look there's there are far worse gates
and there are actually gates subject to
enforcement in the same parish so i i
very much doubt that
that will be an issue but if you if
members want it conditioned that the
design of gates has to be agreed
i don't have an issue with that and i'm
sure the applicant wouldn't
okay
so miss bird are you clear on that
are you happy with that that we've got
that kevin if i could just come back um
could we also condition about lighting
no lighting uh
i'm not sure whether that would be
reasonable i would certainly have to be
low level lighting if there was any
lighting i'd rather see no lighting
[Music]
but i'm looking to mr johnson for
guidance on that
mr johnson um
yeah of course it's not unreasonable but
a condition to control
i mean my own personal views i'd rather
not see any lighting
i recall the previous application
it was going to look like something out
of disneyland
and you know clearly that was a long
that was a while ago there's been a
rethink but i would rather see no
personally i'd rather see that we could
control that there's no lighting
okay
if the applicant's consistent they can
make an application separately otherwise
mr johnson how did you get on with this
solar panel stuff
the blocks and that you put down you
can't condition anything not that can
you or would that
how would that because
i've had this come up before
i don't know that's interesting
due to working where i'll do it howdy we
are selling these blocks and i've got
some of them at home
yeah and i i like search beacons in my
opinion so i think they're too much
i mean i mean i mean
a little less hilarity sorry i know i
love to well if we if we place a
condition on i mean they would need to
be they would need to be a perm a
permanent figure
if they're not a permanent fixture
obviously subject to size and scale and
that sort of thing then we wouldn't have
any control in that sense
okay so sorry miss bird i'll try again
are you are you happy with the proposal
as given
and if you are could you read it back oh
mr councillor stevens again sorry
sorry miss bird hold fire there for a
minute
thank you chuck i'd like to ask a
question about the surface as well it
says it's gravel is there anything to
stop the applicant laying a concrete
drive and then just putting gravel on
top must it remain permeable do we have
any information about that please thank
you
you need to be down wouldn't it just
vanish
i mean
yeah thank you chairman i mean we we
could condition details here
of the
although they've
you know stated what they want to have
at least a surface material we can
submit we can have details which can
include you know the substrate
and how that's to be demonstrated that
it probably meets
um
sustainable urban drainage standards in
a reasonable way that wouldn't detract
from there being a
a substrate of sufficient strength to be
able to take a vehicle because that's
the principles applied to highways
okay
council thank
you know knowing the land around there
you know unless it's got a proper base
it's going to be wet it's going to be
unused it's going to be unusable
it's the appearance and the provide you
know what we haven't got is a strip of
black tarmac
and the surface finish is gravel what is
underneath it be it concrete be it
compacted type one be it whatever
you know it has to be fit for purpose
and now the road you know will have to
be constructed
properly for it to be fit for purpose um
and you know inevitably that is going to
be less permeable than the ground either
side of it but in relation to the area
of ground either side of it it's a very
small area
suggest we move on chairman
yeah
okay i'll try again let me say miss bird
are you can you read us back the
proposal do you think we've got please
we'll cancel it out the cancer dog was
proposing approval uh and additional
conditions in relation to standard and
highways which were mentioned by the
officer will design the gate and no
lighting
that's
standard conditions highways conditions
and we do need the proposed reason for
approval which
miss bird hasn't got so if you could say
your piece please count i know you you
spoke a bit the counselors down but if
you put it into words for us
to i'm not going to ask you for it mr
johnson i'm not announcement
i i hear what you're saying but i didn't
bring that out and i needed to know i
need to know how about the um the
amenity for the homeowner expenditure
right um show of hands please i'm going
to put that proposal those in agreement
one two three four five six those
against
one one abstention so that is granted
with the conditions as discussed
thank you
before we all rush for the door
any items of business the german can
there are none
so members and officers thank you for
your contributions
yes it's closed it's not any other
business
it's chairman considers the urge
but you can talk to me afterwards i'll
draw the meeting to a close at 9 20.
thank you